look Disney Channel we get it you want
to keep your family friendly image and
you do a really great job picking out
child talent but some of your rules are
pretty ridiculous
the set of rules you keep for your
actors are as strict as mother Gotham's
rules for Rapunzel we're pretty sure you
could chill out just a little when it
comes to controlling your stars having a
squeaky-clean reputation might be
valuable but last time we checked having
the freedom to be your true self was
even more important yeah Disney Channel
stars have some crazy strict rules that
they have to follow and Disney is
serious about enforcing them check out
these ten strict rules that Disney stars
have to follow always in character if
you've ever thought that Disney Channel
stars act a lot like the characters they
play you're not wrong just take a look
at Sophia Carson she pretty much is evey
right Disney crafts the perfect image
for their actors and actresses and they
expect them to act like that all the
time
from the way they appear in interviews
to their social media accounts Disney
tells these stars to maintain their
personas constantly hello there it must
be frustrating to never be yourself you
can't wear that is there anything worse
than being told what you can and can't
wear our personal style is how we choose
to present our personality to the world
but Disney Channel stars don't get that
luxury we aren't talking about their
costumes on set Disney tells their
actors what they can and can't wear in
their day-to-day life they even buy a
lot of their clothes for them no wonder
we hardly recognize stars like zendaya
once they are no longer under Disney's
contract they just want to have their
own style a dress suitable for a 16 year
old girl that's coming out of your
paycheck you might one day have a boss
that tells you if you break anything
you'll have to pay for it the same goes
for Disney Channel stars from the
earliest days of the Mickey Mouse Club
Disney had a you break it you buy it
policy get the old stars damaged a
Mickey Mouse hat
Disney would take 50 bucks out of their
paycheck come on
Disney you're the largest media company
in the world we're pretty sure you can
afford a few damaged props cover it up
Disney Channel's main market is kids we
understand that they want their actors
to be as kid-friendly as possible but
they are really strict about how much
skin their stars can show up and they've
been that way since their shows were in
black and white their bathing suits
can't be too revealing and they
certainly can't wear clothes with cut
outs and plunging necklines
no wonder stars like Miley Cyrus are
rockin the clothes they wear these days
don't say that Disney controls
everything about their stars right down
to what they say the actors can't
criticize Disney they can't reveal too
much about their shows and movies and
they have to keep lots of their personal
lives under wraps so Disney Channel
coaches them on how to distract
interviewers they tell them to play dumb
and bring up random things like their
pets all the time there's no such thing
as free speech for a Disney star yeah
major competition Disney Channel has a
lot of stars and they're all hoping to
be the next big thing but things aren't
always so friendly on set there's a lot
of competition between actors and a lot
of it is encouraged by the Disney
Channel Bella Thorne and Sandhya were
forced into a weird competition that
made things really awkward that sort of
attitude affected Miley Cyrus and Emily
Osment to think that's crazy
keep watching to find out the wildest
way that Disney controls their stars
insurance money if you're worth a lot of
money you might want to have a serious
insurance policy it can help protect
your loved ones if anything bad happens
to you but did you know that Disney has
insurance on their stars that way Disney
gets paid even if a star passes away Wow
that is seriously dark but Disney
Channel wants to make sure that they get
all of the money they can off of their
actors it's not just for death either
if a star breaks their contract Disney
will still get all the money they want
autograph education Disney actors and
actresses sign their names a lot and the
Disney coaches teach them on how to have
a good autograph so if you get a
signature from someone like dove Cameron
just note that a lot of work went into
it Disney teaches them how to make a
good-looking and easy to read autograph
the perfect body image it's not just
your wardrobe that Disney Channel
controls it's everything about your body
image Disney Channel stars are expected
to have certain hair colors and maintain
a certain clothing size but then they go
a step further
Disney even controls your fingernails
more sparkles the female stars
especially are expected to keep their
nails short and conservative that means
no wild nail art or bright nail-polish
playing matchmaker if you've ever
noticed that it seems like Disney
Channel stars are always dating each
other it's no coincidence from Britney
Spears and Justin Timberlake in the 90s
to dub Cameron and Thomas Doherty today
Disney stars make it a point to date
co-stars Disney tries to get their stars
to date each other that way they can
really control the image that the public
sees if the stars have to follow the
same strict rules Disney Channel can
avoid relationship scandals but telling
someone who they can date seems way too
controlling would you want to follow all
these rules to beyond the Disney Channel
tell us in the comments thanks for
watching like this video and subscribe
to the things for more great content see
you next time
[Music]